- [Kelly] Those are
cute little sailor pants
- Thanks
- [Kelly] I'm into it
- I know, right?
- Yeah, have you met Gordon before?
- [Cheryl] Yes!
- [Gordon] Yes, we have.
- I actually was a guest on your show.
- That's right, live!
- Yes, live!
- [Kelly] Oh do you, live?
- Yes!
- Amazing!
- [Kelly] Was Snoop there,
did you get anything done?
(laughs loudly)
- No, I missed that one.
- So what's one competition
show you feel like you would
absolutely fail at other than cooking?
- Definitely yours, but also survivor.
I'm more of like
- [Kelly] Oh!
- an indoors girl.
Not so much outdoorsey, you know?
- [Kelly] Here's my thing,
my sister is obsessed,
she loves the show, right?
- [Cheryl] Yeah.
- But like she said she'd
want to do it and I'm like
if I had to do it, I would make it.
I feel like I'm that person.
- Totally.
- If I had to do something
like that I would make it.
Why would I sign up to do it?
- Or make it Naked and Afraid,
probably not.
- But if I had to it, sure!
- [Cheryl] If I had to, survival mode,
- I'm going to survive, I promise.
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I would never sign up for it.
- [Cheryl] No!
- Like eating bugs and like
- [Cheryl] Yeah, and being naked.
- Have you ever eaten bugs, buy the way?
You've probably fried
crickets or something.
- I mean dipped in
chocolate they're delicious!
- [Cheryl] Yeah, right?
- Yeah I mean it's a great source of
- [Cheryl] Real crunchy.
- Yeah, protein as well!
- You're being serious?
- No, no, seriously
I was in Asia and south east Asia.
They depend on those things massively.
- [Kelly] What!
- Vietnam, I mean there's
restaurants that serve bugs.
And then for dessert
they're dipped in chocolate.
You would love them.
- [Kelly] I would love
anything dipped in chocolate.
- [Cheryl] Yeah, same.
- I'm gonna be real with
you, I would try it.
Well speaking of the outdoors,
your husband is obsessed
- [Cheryl] Gosh.
with just animals.
- Yes, opposites attract.
- [Kelly] How many do y'all have?
- You don't like animals?
- No I love, I love animals.
But he has reptiles.
So he has like 45 to 50 reptiles
that live underneath us.
No snakes, that was the
deal, I said no snakes.
When we actually dated a
little over a decade ago,
I knew that I was marrying
a guy who loves reptiles,
you know what I mean?
So, it was fine, I said as long as,
- [Kelly] That's a load, 40 to 50?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- Iguanas, that look like alligators.
- [Kelly] Do you have a dog?
- [Cheryl] Yes, a little
Frenchie, she's my little baby.
So I'm like stay far away, yes.
- [Kelly] Is she gonna get eaten?
- She's an indoorsey type dog.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Likes to go on walks, but
stays away from the cages.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay,
Stays away form the cages,
sounds like a great place.
(laughs)
Your partner on Dancing
with the Stars last season
was Cody Rigsby, he was here last year.
So what was he like as a partner?
- [Cheryl] Oh he's amazing.
I mean he's so inspirational.
- [Kelly] So joyful!
- He's so joyful! But he's
also a hard worker, you know,
Like he worked seven days a week,
he wanted to get the routines right
and that didn't come easy, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I just saw so many
different sides to Cody.
Like he is this bubbly person,
but he also has a real
human side to him too,
which was refreshing, for sure.
- [Kelly] Awe, that's cool
- Yeah.
- Well you've been sober three years now,
congratulations, by the way,
- [Cheryl] Thank you!
(applause)
that's amazing.
What realizations you had over that time?
- You know, I've been, I guess
like when I was drinking,
and I kinda used that as
like numbing device, right,
and I'm more of an introvert, at heart.
So, like, doing something
like Dancing with the Stars
I'm able to dance, which is weird,
in front of millions of people.
But having to go to like red carpets,
or like doing the stuff that, you know,
we do in the business
- [Kelly] That's totally
different then the dancing. Yeah.
- [Cheryl] It's totally different.
- Yeah, that's like singing.
That's totally different
when I'm actually doing some
- [Cheryl] Right!
- Yeah.
- [Cheryl] Right. And so like, for me,
dancing was my way of expressing
my emotion without talking,
and then when I started
drinking I realized,
or when I stopped drinking
I realized that I have
social anxiety.
So it was this whole thing of just like
numbing my feelings, not
wanting to, you know,
really go out there in
the world like that.
Like, I love doing my
art, but then like having
to talk, or whatever, it
was really nerveracking.
- Yeah.
- And then I used drinking as
just something for me to be
more outgoing and I thought
it was gonna, like maybe
give me confidence, but
it just did the opposite.
And I also realized, look,
at the end of the day,
you know, it was starting
to be something that I did
seven days a week, and I
was a functioning alcoholic,
and you know I just figured,
you know I need to just
take this one step at a
time and just get healthier
and so I decided
- [Kelly] Good for you!
- a few years ago to stop
(applause)
- And it is interesting though,
because a lot of creative
people that I know,
they might appear as extroverts but
they actually are introverts.
So it's funny you know people
do their thing creatively,
- [Cheryl] Right!
- And then we expect them to be just
these people that love
to talk in interviews,
and love to do,
- [Cheryl] Love to Cha Cha every day.
- Not everybody, that's a
talent, it's a separate thing.
Yeah, so that's, it's very
interesting how people are
forced into those environments.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] And that does
actually make them dependent
upon things they maybe
wouldn't have been, you know.
Well you also have lounge wear.
- [Cheryl] Yes!
- Its a lounge wear line, right?
- [Cheryl] Yeah.
- [Kelly] So could you tell
us a little about that?
And I love that it's comfy.
- It's comfy and it's chic.
I lived in my husbands,
I don't know about you guys,
but I lived in my husbands
sweatpants and t-shirt
over the pandemic.
- [Kelly] I did not over the pandemic.
- No, no you didn't.
(laughs)
- No. Nope.
- And I was just like, you know what,
we need something comfortable for women
that still look really cute
and structured, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- For me, you know I
have body image issues,
- [Kelly] So cute!
- [Cheryl] But I also love like,
being comfortable and being
able to wear certain things
and also slowly transitioning
from the pandemic to
the real world, you know?
People don't necessarily
want to wear dresses
every single day, or dress up,
but you can dress this
down and dress it up
- [Kelly] I love it, yeah!
- And you can just throw on wedges,
it just depends on like how
you're feeling, I guess.
But for me, you know the
jumpsuit and the actual t-shirts
are so structured that it
gives the illusion of a smaller waist,
it's like for all shapes and sizes,
- [Kelly] I'm in!
- It's really comfortable.
- I love it, it reminds
me whenever I saw it,
it reminds me of like, anytime
I've ever worked with dancers
you can tell when y'all walk in.
- [Cheryl] Right.
- Because you look so cool.
You're wearing the like most casual thing
but it looks elevated some how,
and it looks like how dancers
look when you enter a room
and we're all like, oh.
What does that feel like,
when you walk into a room
and look so cool like that?
I don't know.
Anyway it's cute.
- And then you see me like walk normally
and I'm like slouched over.
It's just like when have
to be on, like we're on,
but then we're like
really just slouched over
for the most part.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
Candice, sorry.
My stylist is like yeah, sit up straight.
So we're cooking with Gordon next.
So what are we making?
Is it hard?
We're not cooks.
- It's gonna be amazing.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- We'll get this thing
done in under ten minutes,
fingers crossed.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- A beautiful shrimp pasta.
- Microwave?
- No microwave!
Come on, girl!